[Music]
headlines that describe bias in medical
research and in the worst cases fraud
it's not just journalists that are
contributing to this kind of critical
genre here are several titles book
titles written by academics and
physicians the books on the left are
worried about what critics take to be
spurious disease categories diseases
like attention deficit disorder or
depression or female sexual dysfunction
the books in the middle are worried
about the drugs themselves critics take
to be highly ineffective or harmful
interventions and the books on the right
are worried about the nefarious role of
industry in performing medical research
these aren't cranky outsiders so these
are some of the most prominent
physicians in the world today so this
title for instance Marcia Angell
angel was the chief editor of the New
England Journal of Medicine for many
years the book in the corner here is by
our colleague David Healy who's standing
on the back Ben Goldacre many of you
know as a prominent journalist and
physician here in England Goldacre
took an extract from this book and
published it in The Guardian titled his
article the drugs don't work so these
these authors are articulating several
different kinds of criticisms about
medicine my personal favorite title in
this genre is by the epidemiologist
Peter gucchy who's one of Europe's most
important epidemiologists the title of
his book is deadly medicines and
organized crime
I'll just read one passage from the
editor of The Lancet so The Lancet is
one of the world's you know greatest
medical journals here's what the chief
editor of The Lancet says afflicted by
studies with small sample sizes tiny
effects invalid exploratory analyses and
flagrant conflicts of interest together
with an obsession for pursuing
fashionable trends of dubious importance
science has taken a turn towards
darkness so I'm curious about this turn
towards darkness as a philosopher of
science I've made it my job in the last
few years to try to make sense of this
critical genre about medicine in my view
these authors are contributing to a
general skeptical thesis about medicine
that I call medical nihilism which is
the view that we ought to have little
confidence in the effectiveness of novel
medical interventions so I've just
published a book titled simply medical
nihilism in which I try to bring
together the various skeptical argument
arguments about medicine assess the
extent to which they're persuasive and
well the punchline is on the whole I
find the relatively persuasive so what
I'm gonna do in the next say 15 or 20
minutes is describe the key arguments
for medical nihilism but before I do I
want to note two rather obvious facts
one is this kind of skepticism about
medicine contradicts what appears to be
a real enthusiasm about medical
interventions today so this is a chart
that graphs sales of pharmaceuticals in
in the billions of dollars over the
decades and you can just see it's sort
of rising and rising and rising and
rising so we the Royal we patients
physicians policymakers regulators we
have what seems to be an unbridled
enthusiasm for medicine
another kind of motivating fact that is
both interesting and sort of obvious is
that skepticism about medicine has been
around a long time you can dive through
texts even by Hippocrates and find a lot
of skeptical proclamations about
medicine so here for example is a
passage from Dryden better to hunt in
fields for health on BOTS than fee the
doctor for nauseous draft the wise for
cure on exercise depend God never made
his work for man to mend so lived our
sires here doctors learned to kill and
multiplied with there's the weekly Bill
okay so we see there's three assertions
here that in fact are the three key
arguments in that critical genre in
those books that I just had had up on
the slide so one is that diseases
themselves are just the kinds of things
that are in principle futile to treat so
Dryden is saying God never made his work
for man to mend another is a kind of
skepticism about the interventions
themselves the drafts are nauseous you
should just do some exercise and then
the third is this worry about the
corrupting influence of money they
multiplied their weekly bill so we see
those three arguments appear over and
over and over again through the
centuries including in this critical
genre today this is a woodcut by Goya
Goya is depicting a physician as a
donkey and the inscription says I wonder
what she's gonna die from so the doctors
treating a patient I wonder what she's
gonna die from and most commentators on
this woodcut say in fact the patient's
already dead now I like this woodcut for
one reason which is Gaia is a
transitional figure between sort of
early modern Renaissance and late
modernism and so I'm gonna give you
another quote from the middle of the
19th century and Goya kind of nicely
ties
this quote from Dryden - the quote for
the middle of 19th century one thing
that I don't like about this woodcut is
that ghoulia is depicting the problem
being physicians themselves I think that
that's basically a distraction when it
comes to modern medicine today so the
problem and that the problem that
motivates the arguments for medical
nihilism really don't have to do with
physicians so it's not physicians or
other health care workers that are
responsible for the crisis of Medicine
today but rather it's the tools that
physicians have at their disposal and
the way in which those tools get studied
so in the 19th century it was very
fashionable to be what was called a
therapeutic nihilist here is a quote
from the Dean of the Harvard Medical
School who writes if the whole materia
medica could be sunk to the bottom of
the sea it would be all the better for
mankind and all the worse for the fishes
that's the Dean of the Harvard Medical
School okay so medical nihilism holds
that we ought to have little confidence
in the effectiveness of novel medical
interventions now there's many I have
noted three principal arguments for
skepticism about medicine and what I try
to do in my work is bring them together
now I use a formal framework to bring
them together philosophers have a kind
of fetish for logical formalisms
and I'm no different so I use a formal
tool that describes how scientists
confirm their theories and that's just a
kind of glue to bring the various
arguments together so I'm gonna describe
that glue to you for about a minute or
two but don't worry so much about this
glue it's really just a way to bring
together a diverse set of arguments into
a cohesive whole suppose you've got some
hypothesis about a drug like this drug
is effective like this drug that you
want to take is effective
and you've got some evidence for that
drug call it II this is just a publicly
available evidence about the drug this
could be evidence from a randomized
control trial on that analysis whatever
the evidence you've got philosophers
like to model confidence in hypotheses
in the following way by what's called a
conditional probability the probability
that this hypothesis is true given that
you've got this evidence the handy thing
about conditional probabilities is that
there's a little mathematical theorem we
can apply called Bayes theorem which
gives us the following results this is
just visitors math you'll just have to
take my word for it so once we've got
this handy theorem on on the page we can
use the different terms in the theorem
to represent different aspects of
scientific reasoning this term is called
the likelihood which represents the
impact of evidence on your hypothesis
this term is called the prior
probability of the hypothesis which is
just your background belief in the
hypothesis before you got this evidence
that you in fact got what's the
probability that that hypothesis was
true this term the prior probability of
the evidence represents the reliability
of the methods that generated the
evidence that you got I'm gonna unpack
all this in a minute or two so there's a
master argument for medical nihilism
which holds that this term is low the
likelihood is low the prior is low and
the expectancy of the evidence the
probability definites is high that all
entails that this term that represents
your confidence in the hypothesis ought
to be low so it's once it's packaged
this way the argument is just a
deductive argument that follows from
three premises these are the three
premises for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you